[Music]
um
and yeah i think i'll just turn it over
to susan so we can get rolling
thanks we just wanted to say
what a privilege and honor it is as
mighty performing which is a
collaboration
with the center for art science and
technology at mit and its music and
theater department
to be working with lions jaw and all of
these fantastic artists
we're obviously very much looking
forward to future years where we can all
do it in person but it's such a such a
fabulous honor to still be able to
participate in this way
um and after that i'll just hand it
right over to one of my very favorite
professors and artists
tommy defrance thank you susan
okay well jess erica
here there hi start with um yeah
let's start with um i've let my candle
to ground
my being alongside you as we work
through some ideas together
i'm broadcasting from north carolina
and we're on unseated lands of the
chicory the eno
and the catawba people
and i begin with gratitude to have some
time with you
to go through some stuff
and see where we need to be where we are
and hopefully maybe where we want to be
so let's start in easy with the
acknowledgements you need to do
the queer you need to bring into our
group tonight and also
the the essential how shall you prefer
to be addressed by others this evening
so where are you how are you what are
you where are you
how are you what are you let's start
there
i love that whisper that felt really
tender um thank you can i
and am i hurt okay perfect
um i'm coming in and immediately i'm
feeling
um i'm in my home and i feel a little
nervous but i'm reminded that i'm in my
home
and that we are just having a
conversation
and people are also here to you know
they want to take part in that
conversation
um and so i remind myself to breathe and
breathe deeper um and remember that um
i'm
uh in brooklyn and i've been here uh
the whole time you know years um
what where am i i feel a little um
[Music]
what do i need what am i bringing in i'm
bringing in gratitude for this
conversation i'm really grateful to be
here with you all
especially after our first conversation
the other day
and i'm remembering um that
it is just taking it one day at a time
right now
and through and with as much love and
gratitude for our hearts as possible for
getting us here
um and um just pretty i should have said
that first and foremost
um and you can refer to me as jess
you see her pronouns um and that's
that's that erica i'll give it over to
you
hello i'm erica nichols um
i'm also at home because this is where
we are
uh my current home is in toronto toronto
canada on uh unseated six nations land
um also i'm gonna figure out how to put
a link because there's
big uprisings going on the 1492 land
back lane
stuff that's happening on six nations
right now and i just feel like because
in canada it's going to be
thanksgiving weekend it's important to
like
uh support the ways that like folks are
doing radical land back
work uh on six nations and also on what
subutan and they're doing some
solidarity across
canada so i'll put i'm gonna figure out
how to do that
because the internet is not my
comfortable space um
and i will send that on to folks if they
want to be doing that kind of support
um or have the ability to send support
our bodies
um yeah toronto i was so nervous
to have the conversation before we all
we had our like pre-convo the other day
and then i was like oh these people are
magical so i'm actually got really
excited and then as soon as
i saw the zoom then i had a small like
oh
um and so uh
i talked to my sister and i said that i
was feeling fancy because
mit and nervous because
mit and she told me to wear velvet
so melanie nichols i'm wearing velvet
she says you can't feel nervous
and wear velvet for very long you can't
feel nervous for very long while you're
wearing velvet
and i'm wearing uh just to call some
queer
loves who are not on
the planet anymore just a little love to
glam drew henderson
who uh is my partner and this is their
this is their uh this is grief month so
i'm wearing extremely fancy shoes
in honor of them right now so
oh and how to address me they me
great they you yes please
it's funny too um the the addressing
part i prefer tommy as a pronoun
and i like it sort of in every iteration
even if it kind of changes how language
gets operated
i'm often thinking about how um there's
some
some artists who uh kind of choose
pronouns that help
help us kind of reset ourselves and
re-orient ourselves towards
us something else and it's it's amazing
because that's what we're
going to try to talk through um tonight
and over these three days
as part of lion's jaw the virtual
iteration
this idea of queer futures um seems to
be
super important especially in these
moments of grief
which are distended moments that just
seem to go
on and on and on which is part of how
rona
is positioning us among each other
and away from each other but we're also
trying to figure out how to be
towards each other so i really wanted to
see how
orientation could be a kind of modality
we could think together through making
and being near each other
what is near look like across zoom
and also these three kind of gathering
notions we have for tonight
i put them in the chat but i had
suggested them to us
displacements attachments
proximity i was thinking about them
in relationship to queer phenomenology
maybe
maybe queer orientation is a way we want
to
sort of move or imagine together um
but definitely in terms of this queer
resistance
and i'm thrilled that you wanted to
bring a kind of queer ancestor
in to our grouping tonight to see
where they need this to go as well but
let's start with displacements
grief may be displaces in a way i'm
wondering about that
um i'm thinking about what it portends
to be
here and not here which is maybe that
moment erica you were mentioning where
everything's okay i'm at home
and then zoom suddenly there's a bunch
of people in front of me
but i'm here and not here where am i um
so again this idea of displacement
let's start there where shall we go
i feel like we were talking a bit about
um that
like uh
if i'm locating my myself or my body
in grief um or when i'm
actually no talk about it in terms of
love so if i'm talking about it in terms
of love
which seems like an easier place to
start maybe
um if i love someone
yeah then i uh i
i have an embodied feeling of that love
going
to that body and coming back and
you know bouncing off of me right
and so um and and so when that person no
longer has a body
or they've died then my this is i feel
like this is a bit we've been talking
about the abyss and right so what is the
abyss and the abyss is when it just goes
goes and goes and goes and doesn't
bounce back
um and i feel like that it's a
little bit of an epic way of talking
about talking about a zoom
conversation but uh i feel like one of
the
one of the ways that that kind of grief
which is grief for loss of
of folks that we've that died there's
also this like grief for
being in proximity with each other and
being able to feel
the physical affect of what's going on
with us in a room
and then this thing of like how do we
then make a conversation that makes
space for
the the displacement of all of us not
being in a room together but also then
like
how do we locate the distance between
our bodies and then feel that
bounce back and so i think maybe i'm
talking about
proximity rather than displacement but
something like that
i don't know i think if i may jump in
oh that's what the whole point is for me
to jump in if i want to do that um
yeah i'm thinking about like yeah like
what it means to
to hold grease and to hold this
placement
um i was talking to a friend leslie
who's
indiana hey about like the need for
like missing like body work i used to
manage an acupuncture clinic and so like
a lot of like
just like just like the touch of the
body which like i can get into
like what you're talking about erica
missing kind of the physical
um being around people and
energies and those kind of like live
connections but and also like what it
means to hold
all of the loss of that in the body um
and how like my body um you know feels
feels differently like i'm sore in
different places you know i'm
sore more often or i know like three
different people who like threw their
backs out last week like
these different ways in which we're
asking the body to carry a lot more now
than what it's used to um and what it
means to then like
process the loss of our physical
um relationships to people to connection
um in greece which is grief is already
held in the body
um and so not have hold so much of it
for so long
um and what that feels like so i've been
thinking about like you said
displacement tell me i think about
uh intimacy i think about like the the
want the desire for that so then it also
brings up desire
intimacy um and what it means to like
i this is the first time that i was like
oh like this place and thinking about
like
um i like take like maybe like this
identification
approach like a women's approach of like
what does it mean to like
this i like this place inside of like
the place right so then like being home
like i'm i'm home but i'm also in public
and i'm it's like no longer in my home
and it's no longer just my living room
like i have to be very aware of like my
cat going
across me and just kind of like
different performance of what home is
um which is there for me like home is
like such a it's a
it means something i cut it off from the
rest of the world i don't i like to work
at home or you know whatever
i'm going into a lot of tangents um and
i'm not speaking slow as i promised
my apologies to the asl interpreter but
i'm going to work on it
um yeah that's over those are my
thoughts which doesn't mean
that's period no yeah that's a fine
place to
to keep threading us together this idea
of of
i'm curious about home as a side of
of sort of renewal and you know remember
when starbucks was kind of pushing this
three places in their capitalist agenda
of you know your home and your office
and then this third place where you're
gonna
do other things and have another kind of
orientation literally
towards your life um but now we're
displaced literally
into these other ways of thinking about
what any one space can
be and then maybe it does sort of beg
the question of how we
literally orient our home spaces as you
were saying like the performativity of
home but you know
what else can home do especially if
we're trying to imagine queer homes
um you know what what are the terms of a
queer home
if it then also has to accommodate a
kind of queer public or a non-queer
public
like how do we you know how do you do
that
um i mean it's making me think about
the the sort of i mean
the in some ways and a lot of folks that
i'm
[Music]
close with like the sort of dismantling
of queer home
that's happened because of covid um
like lots of poly folks being like what
i'm with one boo
and like and so this whole like then
then are you then monogamous because
you're in and only you know and so that
that it's
that like what are the ethics of home
and then what are the performance of
those ethics
in a context where um
where you know the the safety level and
the
whether you have folks who have um
immune compromised situations and so
like what are these ways that we're
actually displacing um
the identity of our ethics inside of how
we think about what we're doing at home
uh as queer can um
and this has been a thing where i feel
like
you know you know [ __ ] the world around
have been like
erica am i still a [ __ ] and i'm just
like yes boo
you are we're still like it's just
there's there is like
are we allowed uh to claim or
hold or still define ourselves in this
way
um as queer [ __ ] and this this is
something that i feel like there's a
displacement of identity that's
happening inside of queer home
making during covid um and
yeah this thing about like what is our
orientation towards our identity as
queer paulie or whatever uh folks
um when the access to
what feels at home in terms in terms of
your sexual practices or what feels at
home in terms of your partnership
practices is not really available
um that's what i was thinking about when
we're getting in this
mode here i mean you were just like
saying like the the practice like it's a
loss of practice right so
it's like without the practice am i
still saying
i'm like oh like how was my identity
like i didn't our identities have
shifted right because we are no longer
in that practice so then
if i'm probably like am i now am i like
am i not poly right now like
if if i'm not actively doing the thing
um
and like what are ways then that we can
hold on to those or recreate those or i
mean
not recreate because that like alludes
to like kind of like going
back to like finding it and we can't go
back
um but yeah like what does it mean then
to i guess uh
locate again like these practices to
keep those parts of us
alive because i think that what is
really beautiful about queer identity is
that it allows for so much right as we
were talking through the night about
like we
want to leave space for like travel and
to allude to different things um and to
imagine like otherwise constantly and
have the freedom to do that without
being pinned down
to a thing um and so yeah i think
that's what i'm really been grappling
with for people that i know like
what is it who am i without these
practices and am i without the practices
or
like you know and i don't know if i hold
the price it's like if the tree falls in
the forest and no one hears it like
if i'm practicing home by myself but no
one's around to witness it am i still
practicing you know myself
i'm only a [ __ ] with myself do am i
still a [ __ ] or whatever
right you know but yeah exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah it kind of tilts towards
this question of attachment though too
you know so what is it to be attached to
a practice
you know slutting or [ __ ] shaming which
is usually the practice people practice
on me
but that's a part of this conversation
and you know like so then
you know if i can't exercise the
identity that needs to be [ __ ] shamed
kind of constantly
what am i attached to about that then
you know where
where do we want to put a question of
attachments around practice
and you know queer can and queer home
and a bit like how do we what like i
think that there's also this uh
for me i feel like um in
like dance folks i feel like there's
there's a difficulty in naming that we
actually have methods
um and i think that this this i feel
like a is a place where i'm always
like um when i especially in teaching
context where folks don't consider the
way that you do things
over time and like practices as being
methods
uh and so like what are the strategies
as you know queer folks are like in my
case like a
like a queer you know dance weirdo
that's all over the planet regularly
teaching in these like little moo loop
kind of ways um
like what are the ways that like what
are my strategies and methods for being
in touch with people who i
love and and family with all over
um and how do i how does that those
how are those practices shifting because
of
uh well yeah another moat
like this other abyss of like when will
we see
each other irl again and so um
it's a bit like the practice like uh
this kind of hubris of like oh i'll see
those folks again
and then the the reality and that
includes my blood family it's like
you know what is the reality of um
the kind of communication the kind of
upkeep practice the kind of family can
uh like togetherness practices that
we're doing that feel different
and more like honestly more high drama
uh because of their the
because of the the not knowing project
that's happening
yeah like i used to talk in a way like
uh i feel like when i think about like
kind of two relations like whatever like
my relation with my mom
like my mom and i used to be real cash
when we would be like oh yeah we'll see
each other soon but now it's just like
oh no
we're both having a hard time so it's
like we're hoarding the cookies of the
the difficulties no and then so this
when
if we're holding on to oh oh i got i
can't i can't call my mom right now
because
you know there's just been a [ __ ] storm
of stuff for a whole month or something
like this right and then with other
folks like
my boo who lives in amsterdam it's like
a shift has happened where it's like now
we are deciding we are talking to
we were talking every other week we've
got a date we
like so like kind of like uh
what is a casual what feels casual in
one way feels very uncasual and another
depending on what the relation is
like what is the formalization that has
to happen so you know that i love you
and
and i know that you love me yeah
something like this i don't know
it's just i mean there's also some sorry
you're gonna go for it
there's also something about like having
to be intentional
about that now right erica like where
it's the the kind of like last minute or
spontaneous choice is gone which is what
a lot of us are on
the the the the being like oh i can go
to amsterdam this weekend like
real quick and then pop over here and
then pop or i can like go and like
hit the park and hit this and hit the
van like hit that i can go all up and
down like all the boroughs like one day
and it's like
no there has to be something more about
intention and also space between those
things
right um and like what it means to have
to like go somewhere and then quarantine
for two weeks and then like
sit there and go somewhere else it's the
formalization that you were that's the
word that you were using but yeah i
think that it's like
an intention and planning that like
maybe like is not interesting normally
um oh my god my cat is freaking out look
at this
that's katrina davenport extravaganza
matteo
say hello yes please yeah green boat
kitten i'm like
speaking of speaking of high drama like
this one
um but i'm also like the need for drama
like the oh like the
the beautiful like the beauty of like
the like performance
in like queer culture like queer kinship
like all of my people like
being being able to like like do this
like step into the light
and and there's the light the light is
like not
around slash like i don't i don't know
it's harder
harder to locate these days um which
then is like something it was like joy
and pleasure in there too that i'm still
working out in my mind
also like the pleasure and like and i
feel like you know when we're talk i
think about like fam adornment practices
and the practices of like
how do i feel like all right i'm ready
and like but it is like what am i ready
for like am i ready for this zoom
meeting
uh i mean i feel ready
i'm wearing a wearing a real great shoe
but it but it's actually for me like
what
like i'm noticing that in terms of like
my my
uh yeah my the feminine the femme
adorned practices adornment practices
that i need in order to be like
boom business time um which for me is
like literally leaving the house
um so like to be in that mode it's like
uh i actually feel like that's been
something that's
been a constant that that practice of
femme adornment that's like yeah
lipstick before i leave the house even
if i'm going you know
even if i'm literally going nowhere
right if i'm taking a little circle
around the block
like um that's like for me it has been
like a
that this thing we're talking about what
is it to ground sometimes is to light a
candle sometimes it's to call your peeps
and then sometimes it's to put on
lipstick and be like
okay i
my adornment practices are for me and my
relationship with
literally the the planet and so
if there happened to be some people
involved in that yes but i think that
that's something that i realized and
almost in a way like it's like
um it's uh it's feeling like heartening
to be like oh yeah that practice
absolutely hasn't fallen away for me and
that's felt like
oh okay like these kind of things are
like allowing um
that that is i have a very secure
attachment
to um them adornment practices
as a way of like grounding and being
able to be in whatever world is outside
my door
you know and so that feels um
that feels like a thing where i can oh
almost like relax back into it like a
cozy blanket
the cozy blanket of of gender
performance you know
yeah i think
that was great there was something in
there that was um helping me think about
you know in this election cycle and now
i live in the south and i've been here
for 10 years now
but honestly before kovid i was hardly
ever here
like you know like many of us literally
was hardly ever here in durham
um because i was always you know
somewhere else doing something else
but now that i'm here and i noticed
these practices of self-care
that are about the shell that i feel i
need when i am sort of running into
anyone
because the idea of the sort of anyone
in the neighborhood down here
in north carolina gets really tricky and
you know there's just so much
racism obviously obviously this white
supremacy that goes without saying but
the literal racism of the gaze and the
look and the kind of
shell that has to be sort of prepared
so i'm thinking about that kind of
preparation which you know i had like
attachments to a practice
of how to get through the day and where
to go when and you know when to sort of
be ready for something bad to happen
and now things are quite different
because any time going out is
is is its own sort of adventure in a way
and then in this election cycle it's
it's all exacerbated
quite a bit with the signage and you
know which family is going to be down
with like
i'm for the racists and whoever uh you
know whatever those those sort of
rhetorics are
um so i'm thinking about those practices
of queer possibility too
that were daily for me but now i have to
figure out
how i need them now and how to stay
invested in them
i haven't figured that out at all
[Music]
i mean yeah like that
the like figuring out something about
this like being
like the the not duality but the
relationship to like being seen
like wanting to kind of perform like
going out like wanting to put on the
heel wanting to put on the lip wanting
to
like you know like tighten up like
whatever
but then also again like on the very
like same like edge of that spoon
is that like racism of the gays that
you're talking about and that's like
kind of this like
dreamland like nightmare thing that i
talk about a lot in my research where
i'm like
they're very very close like where it's
like um i remember
talking to a friend once and he was like
well it sounds like you don't ever
or you never talk about comfort and i
was like i don't
know if comfort is a term for me like
i've never
sought out comfort or like thought about
like seeking out comfort
because i think about comfort and i was
like i'm sitting here and i'm like oh
what's comfortable and i'm like oh like
a nice
like uh sexy like car with like leather
seats and i'm driving on the highway and
like
cruise control is on and then i'm like
oh and then i'm on the highway and i'm
speeding and there's a cop and am i
going to get it like very quickly it you
know it's always it's always right there
and so
it's like even
and even now like heightened like with
the election cycle like driving around
in areas and i'm like oh
is that like seeing american flags
outside of homes now and i'm like
that means something entirely different
now like you're like it's like what are
you
like you're aligning yourself with
america which america right now is like
charlie
it's it's so nuanced now
um it means so many different things and
so then yeah how to keep
alive how to keep the flame under the
queer possibility how to keep the flame
under that like
yeah how to keep the kind of like it's
like in the house like how to keep the
jack going through all of it
um and but if you're like me the last
few months i'm just like
i'm just trying to walk left and then
right you know so it's
it's it's different it's different work
it's different work um and it's doing
the work of like
um like you have to you have to build
the club
like get the foundation get the drywall
like get the lights build the bar get
the
drinks get the and dude and be the dj
and you know versus being able to just
like walk out the house like walk into
something already made
and now we kind of have to build the
whole world for ourselves to walk into
which is like not always not true but
especially right now you know
well and also like i'm up in canada
right now and it's there's a distance
that's like a crazy distance from my
family in the states and
obviously i'm not black and i'm not
dealing with that kind of
racism but there's this thing that makes
me think about
um the ways that like queer flagging and
how we
identify safety like so what are the
safeties that we end up
um yeah like what are the ways that we
are we signal to each other safety like
i'm a safe
you know and it's all relative safety so
it's like the the
the uncomfortability of what it's like
to be
concerned about the violence coming on
on bodies is the
is the like the place which the
invention of
like fam adornment or you know the way
people are hanky coding or the way folks
are doing
other sorts of things to signal like
relative safety
inside a violent arena
which is outside so this makes and i
think that there's something about like
especially early pandy where it was just
like it are we
in a horror movie like there's so much
space
like that this the the space between
bodies and like just the general
you know um like fear that people have
of each other's bodies that
has been like showing itself and then
coming and going away like this moment i
felt like early pandy where
white cis men were were afraid of
getting near other people
like it was only for like a very split
second in like this very big
like very early pandy where like people
were like oh no we don't know what this
is and so there's like
actually like getting out of the way for
people that
i noticed that i was just like i this is
something
like and getting less cat calling also
and so like this kind of ways of being
noticed in the street and
super like it just being like
yeah for a moment i recognized that
white cis men had fear on the street
which was something that i had never
really experienced
before and that
that like that was [ __ ] really weird
to be like moving and like having having
the space not be taken up
in the grocery store or something like
this in this kind of like not just
pushing through space
in the way that i have
like experienced is this men doing and i
don't know if that's what other folks
experiences
are but that like for sure was something
that i noticed it's like very early
pandy where people were afraid of each
other
in a different way yeah
no that's that's yeah it definitely was
true in the places where i was as well
but it snapped back pretty quick
and it snapped back to you know the
joggers taking over the sidewalk
and you better get out of their way it
did snap back and you you know you
mentioned that
but it was this kind of moment that that
did
did sort of tilt towards uh oh [ __ ]
this could be uh something else and you
know one thing that
um as queers were always really obsessed
with of course because it's part of what
what queer might be about is like what
else could there be couldn't there be
something
else where you know what else could how
what's an otherwise way
you slow down sorry an otherwise way for
us to be
um and this question of proximity
somehow
so these bodies as you were saying that
would get out of the way briefly or be
fearful in public in ways that was
was different but then what's what's
near now so proximity and nearness
seems urgent as makers
whether it's proximity to folks uh to be
involved in an experiment or a project
or a workshop
or a making or experiencing it
i mean we're all getting used to these
screens and we're approximate to the
screens in really different ways than we
were
six months ago eight months ago but how
is proximity unfolding
for you and your making being querying
queering um now what what do you have to
have near
what is it to be proximate for you
erica you want to give it a whirl
um yeah what do what do i need to be
near
um the ground
as much as possible um trees
uh being with uh the land that i'm on
and being
[Music]
being outside as much as possible has
been like
you know it's always been a thing that's
absolutely necessary and then just
general like
this isn't necessarily proximate like uh
proximal but i feel like inside of my
practice like
my practice of now which is this two
weeks every two weeks i'm doing this
femme meditation thing with carly
boyce who's a friend and long-term
collaborator and we're tattooing each
other
while we're talking about grief and
death and so
it's actually this thing of like in a
way
it's a marking it's a time marking thing
so it's really like
acknowledging that like this is you know
we're like in the beginning we're like
okay this is gonna be a thing that lasts
for like a hot minute
and then we'll do you know but now you
know 12 episodes in
you know um her tattoo that i did on her
finished
and we're just like and then what
happened
so um i think that that that practice
has
has helped make it be like okay this is
like what is it to mark actual body
space time
um and and and hold
and hold space for the for that to be
something that we're not
pretending isn't happening um
that the yeah that feels like part of it
um and then that the grief with
so it feels like the prop i mean what am
i proximal to
proximal to the levels of grief and how
that that thing it makes me think a bit
about the way that jess was talking
about the holding of grief
um at like earlier about and like what
is it to hold grief
in these different ways over time um
and that that feels um
that that feels like a constantly
unfolding thing
where it's like the if you if if i try
to hold
you know if i try to hold hold hold it
all then
i do feel like i'll throw my back out
knock on wood right and so what are the
new ways and what are the
what are the old ways that i can connect
to from
remembering that like how do i move it
through how do i move it through how do
i move it through
and yeah i mean
[Music]
uh waking up
waking up regularly to more death
and how to not both to to both not
not leave space it's like how do we not
normalize
that and also be there for ourselves and
the people we love
and i'm just like i don't know
you know um
yeah i don't know if i answered that
question at all
you did it was yeah
uh like processing and also trying to
speak i'm like
take time um but i'm thinking
i'm thinking about
the like needing like the needing to
constantly ask this question of like
what do i need what do i need to be near
because it does change because like as
like more time goes on as more deaths
happen
as i mean i've said this before that
like every day now feels like
post-election 2016
every single day and so there's kind of
like the the pride the swallowing of
like the big
pill and then being like and i have to
like answer
[ __ ] emails or teach a class or you
know show what i have to show up
um and i'm thinking that
it's really interesting because for the
first time in my life a little bit i'm
needing
nature and space and i'm needing
to like be outside and go on hikes and i
grew up on the west coast like born in
durham like grew up in the west coast
and i'm like a beach girl like through
and through
but i need treats i need like
and then what i've like what i'm
realizing now is that i need
the space i need to be able to see
and not see not see through fear
like living in brooklyn like it's been
like where i
am it's like people who have lived here
for forever like you know they've been
the ones who've been pushed back from
manhattan and beds die and like you know
like so now like where you know
so people have been knowing me here for
years not going anywhere
um and so there's always still a lot of
people on the street and i'm a person
who like i love people i love
connections but i
walk outside and all i see is like the
fear of people not having their masks on
of people being close
so like the world you described of like
white men moving out of the way i'm like
what in the non-brooklyn was that like
it's it's all it's still the same here
unfortunately it's still
it hasn't shifted like people still
don't move on the street and especially
like
it becomes a kind of like i dare you to
like um
it feels very allah like trump making
fun of died and wearing a mask it's like
no this is a real thing and like we had
two neighbors die within a month of each
other upstairs
like directly upstairs from us like in
the building
and so like just like literally the like
literal proximity
to death to disease
to like sickness and like just the fear
and the anxiety that takes over and so
like
it's normally i see people and i'm like
yeah like
you don't move out of my way like i'm
going to show them to you i'm going to
move because this is my face too like
whatever and now i'm like
terrified of being around all of these
bodies
and being all these people that i don't
know so it's like they're on one side
i'm like
oh the the need of like being close to
people that i know
and hugging people and like hugging
different people and you know feeling
the different love
and also like wanting to be very far
away from those that i don't
because of the the like just the
yeah i don't know and it also has them
to do like a kind of like disregard then
for bodies like i think that the only
people who really know how to stay far
apart
are performers like people who are body
workers who like have an awareness of
their babies right
i'm like in the grocery store
and it's kind of like true true and i
don't think i don't think that it's
malicious most of the time i've assumed
that people literally just have no idea
how consequential their body is how
consequential their presence is
which is really beautiful like we all
like we all matter our like
our presence means something and also
like the kind of like taking in
um but yeah i've needed like space i've
needed like
more time to process things like i can't
go
straight through 8 a.m to 8 p.m you know
i need time in between to kind of like
digest and to process and to take more
time for myself to recenter
um because i feel a lot more sensitive
now i feel a lot more like
um sensitive is the only way i can think
of but i'm like i need more i need time
to like get back to my
anger i can't walk away from her all day
and then come back to her and be fine i
need to like know that she's like right
there
um which is great in many ways because
it just like sets more boundaries
right but i'm not just like working and
then i'm like oh it's 6 p.m and i
haven't eaten anything
i'm like no like you're making
grand meals every time and that just
feels really necessary
um but it's like i mean i'm always
talking about needing more time and i
think that that's
what's really beautiful about queerness
is that we can create those times
um but i always i mean i always want
more time more
ways to imagine and to follow
the different pockets and you know like
daydream and
yeah it feels in that in that in that
healthy way
i'm remembering that i'm reading berlin
and i'm like i'm not too far in the
future girl i'm still here
i know this [ __ ] is [ __ ] up wait which
brillant can you
yeah which one are you reading oh cruel
optimism
because if you need a book that is
literally every sentence you read where
it's just like this is right now
that's the one um but i mean it's just
it's just
you know it's it's it's keeping your
toolbox like ready you know it's just
like something to read where it's like
it's um and she wrote it kind of closer
to
uh like the wall street crashing in that
financial crisis and that political
crisis
so it's funny because she's referencing
like these things that i'm like
no that's same same same for literally
right now
um but it's been really really um great
to read and also it's
it's very much like i'm looking at you
right in the eyeballs and i'm not
letting off so it can be a lot but
yeah i'm thinking about this idea that
we need
we need a kind of moreness to keep
imagining queerness and
and exploring out but then there's also
this
concern around people we don't know um
you know that contradiction that tension
in there
so it's like how do we keep imagining um
imagining beyond or towards something
else um
as we're we're busy with being among
the people we're already busy with being
among so then
how how are you doing that how are you
so reading is one way
obviously but how else are you finding
the possibility
to keep exploring things you might not
think
to do or be or to be of or among
in this time when it's it seems really
challenging to be
near people that we don't know you know
this idea if you don't know them it's
not clear
how they're going to come at you or how
we're going to go towards them how we're
going to orient towards each other
what do you do with that
i mean i'm thinking a bit about um
like this idea of like what what has to
replace what we cannot
do yeah um and like
yeah this this feeling of like okay for
example like
like dancing i do a lot of dancing that
involves touching people
or uh brazilian jiu-jitsu which is just
literally the least coveted friendly
martial art that exists because
everybody's
grills all up in each other's everything
it's like very smooshy face crotch and
face
submission wrestling basically um
and so it's like when i activate like
what are the things that
for example juju like brazilian jiu
jitsu was doing
for me one of the things is
keeping me from dissociating another
thing is me negotiating how close i get
to being
not okay right and so that
like long-term negotiation so that's one
thing and then also just you know 20
hours a week of moving minimum
uh and and and being in this push
real like tension physical tension with
other bodies
uh super uh strategic thinking
improvisation um muscle
stuff like all muscle muscle stuff and
also negotiating
um being like a non-binary body in
in very straight spaces which is another
like that's another thing but that's the
part that i don't totally miss as much
um but they're like okay so let's say
for example there's like you know
there's there's
uh like my friend was saying like so
there's 12 things and that are happening
that are happening in this complex form
of dancing or of martial arts that is
that that is being done
and so what are the things that must
that you can't replace it with one thing
you need to replace it with 12 things
and none of those are going to be the
thing
but they're all going to be a place that
a way that you're spending your time and
orienting yourself toward that is not
what you have or
what i have been orienting myself toward
and so just kicking the desk some of
those things i feel like are um
like old ways of care taking myself so
like
when my partner died i was like yes i do
run 10k a day
so this like what are those things that
are activating but then also
um yeah like the other like what are the
other things
that are emerging this sounds really
cheesy but i make a lot of roasted
chicken
um you know so i feel like this thing of
like food making
and like feeding myself and my love is
feeling like
a future a queer futuring practice um
and and i know that this is also like
the very old thing for many people
um but if it were left up to me it would
be a carrot and hummus for like the rest
of you know i'm just like i'll put the
food in do the things
and so because of this not put the food
in do the things
um there's an there's a different
like uh feeling of time and feeling of
sustenance and being able to be
uh yeah i mean that's like one of the 12
things but i do think that roast chicken
as a as a queer futuring practice i
don't know if that exactly works but it
does feel
in a way like a a different
concept of time than the the kind of
hustle
um that i feel inside of um
the general practice that that i i i was
in yeah i mean it's like nourishment
right like in the kind of like a little
more luxurious
nourishment um and we're pescatarian
households
but like also taking the time to really
elaborate
in the meals i'm like i'm gonna take the
time
to make this paul hollywood eight flat
low like i'm gonna take the time
because that's what makes me feel good
and it also like
literally feeds us like nourishes our
body takes care of us makes it make sure
that we're still going like
i'm thinking about like patricia collins
and like black feminist thought like
getting out of bed is a [ __ ] radical
act for a black woman like
feeding yourself making sure that you
can make it to tomorrow
is a radical act in a time when like
the downfall of us you just like prayed
on all the time
and it's like i'm gonna take this time
to make this meal and find joy in it or
i'm gonna take the time to like
you know like research this thing or
like go get that thing that like makes
me feel good like saying
yes to those like small like what seem
like
small pleasures like saying yes to like
decades like
in ways that don't feel like traditional
like in terms of like i think people
think of like treating yourself as like
monetary but it doesn't have to do i
mean food cost money like yes you know
that but like
also like in these tiny like treating
yourself with like
time like it takes time to roast the
chicken it takes time to like get that
girl out take the insides out like
struggle with all the goods and you get
to like and you
and there's something about it too
that's repetitive and so you're like i
know how to do it it's something that we
know in a time of so much unknown like
someone's more unknown than normal it's
something you
like if you don't know [ __ ] else is
gonna happen today you know that you're
gonna make
a [ __ ] chicken like you know and it's
gonna turn out good because you've made
this chicken
fidget top you know and it's like
treating yourself to that to like be
like they seem small but like they just
for me right now
mean so so much like i'm like i can't
i'm like i can't like open my journal to
like write this essay that i think i
need to write because that's like you
need to do something productive with
this time
or like i don't feel like i can face
myself in the studio with my own
practice
but i can make like this beautiful
salmon and like this chimichurri sauce
and he's like carrot like
i can do i can do that and so i will
i'm clicking oh
you know i was going to do the thing
where you just repeat everything you say
at the end
but we've already heard it so okay first
of all i can't wait till we meet and get
to cook for each other
i also think like this thing of like
feeling like
um you are feeling like i have speak in
the i statements
like feeling like i know what
what use i am in the time when [ __ ] goes
on
right but like right now
i'm not strangling anybody because i got
these talents because then like that's a
coping mechanism for me to like be able
to not feel
because i can't train so right now i'm
not strangling anybody
because i can't because i'll break my
fingers
um but it's just this thing of like what
this thing again we come back around to
like what is the identity of what i
imagined myself to do in the queer
future revolution
like uh against white supremacy and all
this stuff is like i imagine that i
would be like you know
my my brother jokes that i'd be head of
hand hand-to-hand combat security
right so like but actually maybe i'm
maybe actually i'm a chicken maker so
it's just like the chicken maker you
know i mean the cook which no one in my
life would ever believe right the
chicken maker
american a close chicken maker but it's
like this thing of like what it
uh that the shifting of our identities
and the shifting of our practices are
actually moving us
to realize that that like we're allowed
we are allowed to be more and we are
allowed to have that
uh like these these i feel on some level
like soft skills
right and so it's not like i don't think
of um
not that i don't think of jiu-jitsu and
self-defense as a soft
art because i do in many ways but um
allowing myself to recognize that like
i am able to and i i am of use
in other ways um that are
both creative and functional and
um possibly with more ease
i'd like to imagine that anyway
that's kind of amazing it's maybe about
a
an opening out towards again yeah i know
i keep hitting us on reorientation
or orientation um and it might start
being tedious so we can move on if we
need to
um but this idea that you know to open
in different directions or
transformative directions that were
unexpected um
towards other kinds of skills and and
practices
what about soul coping mechanisms i
think that was a phrase you actually
used the other day
that i was really taken by and have been
sort of trying to marinate with that
alongside your chicken clearly like this
idea of where
you know but no but yeah like
the mechanisms that again are about a a
reorientation
um one thing i keep saying or are
thinking through is
if i'm doing things that i was doing
eight months ago i wanna
reimagine my own ethical sort of address
to existence or life
um and the values that i you know try to
move
through or towards um because now
says something else tells me something
else so then like
what are you know for you mechanisms
that are
the places of of of soul coping
we talked about practical coping in a
way and that is soul work as well
but are there other orientations that
you have that are
helping you or surprising you along the
way
i'm trying to um i started therapy
because everyone needs to be in therapy
but especially right now and i have no
problem sharing this because
again everyone needs to be in therapy um
and
one of my main goals in this
is to talk nicer to myself
and so because i can i mean like virgo
like just work work work work work work
work work
and like crazy
and so when things fall through and like
they can be
so small or they can be so large i can
be
really really like harsh on myself and
talk
yes um
but i can be really hard on myself in a
way that isn't
it's not helpful and it sends me in a
shame spiral
and that was something i was like that
has to like i can't
like everything else is doing the work
of being down on me like i can't be
on that team as well and so i've been
working on
being nicer to myself and it sounds so
small
but when i realized how often i was
doing it
and how often i had to like you know
pull my own edge back and be like listen
we are not going to
and it's like a lot of my partner too
like she's like so i just need you to
talk nicer to yourself right now
or she'll ask you like when was the last
time you said something like good to
yourself or you complimented yourself
and i'm like i didn't ask for this
dragging right now but i'll take it
um but it's something like that's
something that is helping me
like the treatment of like the me
treating myself better is like slowly
but
it feels like i'm just like tending to
my little heart and a little soul
i'm like because i'm being nicer to
myself
and that is something that like i
totally
never did never took the time to do
because it is work
because it's easier to just be like why
did you do that yeah
and then i'm just like i'm useful for
the day feels like
and that's awful that's awful to feel
that way
um and especially now that so many
things
are again like not happening and not
there i've been working on
yeah just like what is it like to take
some breaths
as i have been trying to say since the
beginning take some breaths before
i react to this thing or just like
inhale exhale
and like keep moving through um
which has also been helped coupled with
taking more time intentional time for
myself
um and because of always being at home
and especially those first couple months
just like all this watching the tv
doing things that before i would define
as a leisurely thing
or relaxing thing because that is the
everything
like oh the time that i need for myself
needs to look different like actually
like
i do still need to take like an hour to
like go for a walk by myself
or go for a bike ride or you know put on
my
or put on my headphones and read or
something
um because it looks a lot different now
what so still careless a lot different
now because everything is kind of
the same thing boundaries are different
so those have been a couple of things
that i've been doing
and i'm still working on every single
day because
the devil is a busy mistress
yeah she's looking blocked on me she's
broken black
i feel like i feel like my partner's
gonna hear if if they hear you saying
that she's gonna be like oh i remember
saying
it's like it is like this this talking
to yourself thing
is so extremely hardcore
and i think that it makes me feel about
[Music]
like i was talking to another martial
artist who has had a very serious injury
and um and she had that right at the
beginning of covid and so
we were talking about like the ways that
like
the the negative self-talk thing is
coming in for her
and then we talked about like sort of
this idea of like
uh fighting form body training form body
and the good samaritan which is like
okay so like fighting form is like
you're
highly stressed your your adrenals are
just like through the roof you are
fully in you're training yourself to be
in fight-or-flight mode like you're
ready to survive right you're ready to
really
um and you have to pump yourself up and
there's strategies for that and that's a
real thing
so if i think about it with dancers i'm
like okay so performance mode when folks
are on tour and they're
underfed and under slapped and under
under under under
and you know being deep in the
commodification of our bodies and all of
this but then
and then there's like training body
which is like what i think
i feel like that's like the comp like if
you they're like relative comfort zone
where it's like i'm engaging
uh in a fight or i'm engaging in fight
and
training through uh like levels of
boundaries that i'm pushing and not
pushing but i'm engaging with them in a
way that i have agency
right where i feel like fighting form
performance form there's a lot
not a lot of agency in that space and so
like this thing of like this training
form is actually the space that i feel
the most comfortable
am i under fed and under slept probably
uh am i running around a lot and trying
to fit too much in and am i over
training
yes right like there's no way of not
saying that so then this idea of like
what is the body of the
fighting form what is the body of
training form and what is the body of
good samaritan form and the body of good
samaritan form is
is a is a body that i have not gotten to
know
uh much in my life and so
this is um new
to try and get to know that that body
and so the stuff that you're saying is
super resonating
uh about like how to talk nice because
it's also like
um what is recognizing a form that i'm
not used to
uh holding and being in you know what is
what is this being in a way like a bit
alien inside my own form
that is not perceivable to anyone else
partially because
not seeing very many people right but
like it's actually it isn't
because that's this thing too around
like but if we're talking like that
it's not about what is showing to others
it's really about this relationship
um that i'm um re-having or re-having to
exist within with myself and how do i
feel about this form and how does this
form feel and what
what's jiggling and what's not jiggling
and what's uh
what is like what is being what is being
hungry and eating
what is being hungry for chicken and
making chicken uh rather than just like
stuffing some food in your face on your
way to train
and so i think that there's this
actually i mean it's all coming
back to chicken i'm so embarrassed okay
cool but
it is it's like you're talking about
this nourishing so it's like
what is it to nourish the body that's
emerging right now
with a different relationship to time a
different relationship
to um what feels like the grading of
grief
yeah like grading not like cheese but
like uh
like uh like cat scratch
of it um
and how how do uh what is the body of
that now
and so how does that how like kind of in
this thing of like what is the soul
coping mechanism is actually to be like
what what's here right now like what can
i feel right now
like like what does it feel like to be
in this particular flesh sack
in this particular moment in this
particular relationship
to time and the people who i'm able to
be touching
and how how much does that uh how can i
notice like how my desire becomes
ravenous
um rather than keeping it in check
and that that i feel like also like sort
of like the soul coping mechanism of the
ravenousness
ravenousness not a word of of like
sexual desire
for myself or for my boo or for whatever
like or for my my booze that are not on
the same continent
like what what what is my relationship
to that
and can i be with that and that somehow
feels both like
extremely um sad
uh and also
i don't know like interesting to be in a
new relationship
to this like proximity desire and the
unknown
and how that relates to like what it is
to feel like being in
this body that i feel like i'm like oh i
know that body i know this body this is
the body i've been in
and but what is it what is it to notice
that the
changing yeah
and not be mad about it or not be right
right and so like you know not be not
what is it to and i mean like or be mad
about it right or
kind of like not be in a judgmental
place um
with the with the process of
re-knowing myself in a different mode
which i haven't spent a lot of time in
at least not in recent memory or maybe
ever yeah
yeah yeah this question of
time just keeps circling back because
there are these
i'm sure well i know i've experienced
these days
that they disappeared where did they go
i have no idea
and i'm a daily journalist you know i
write in my journal every day
and you know the first three or four
months of the rhona i was
reading old journals and then that got
you know at some point
for me that always gets
counterproductive because i get stuck in
the
self-deprecation place like look what i
was thinking then what a ridiculous
thing to think
so i'm thinking just about like you know
talking down to myself across time like
really i can do that and there i was
doing that
[Laughter]
you know and then i had a there were a
couple weeks where i was waking up
screaming
you know in the sleep and these kinds of
lower grade depressions and then deeper
depressions and and finding ways
ways to again sort of reconfigure
uh for me i'm always thinking about
reorienting
um to try to really understand
differently
how ground in time um could operate
in a way that i could um
kind of spread towards or move through
or be of maybe is the best way for me to
think of it
so yeah something about time and the the
days that do
go away if the if that's useful language
but then
it's okay that that happens so taking
care or sort of being gentler
or rethinking time as being like there
can be days or
two or three or four i haven't gotten
beyond four
where there's not productivity in the
old way
of thinking about it before rona
there's a kind of wandering through time
or with time um and allowing for this
emergence of a something else
so that's what i've been i've been after
in terms of trying to
to understand a coping i don't know
no
i mean i'm having like they know
i have to make reminders for everything
like i'm like okay reminder to
call this person reminder to like do
this thing or i will truly like
just lose it like in ways that i mean
there are like
uh like this week so this week was the
13th
year since i've lost my father and i'm
like you like you lose someone you know
the date like you don't really forget it
and this year i literally remembered it
two days later
i was like oh no it's not the fifth it's
the seventh and then my brother was
texting me
on the sixth like hey just checking in
because you know yesterday and i'm like
where in what world like am i
and of course i wanted to first like
just be down and
like you know and it's just like time
it's been like 13 years of a long time
and so
um trying to be
gentler with myself with the loss of
time and the gaining of maybe other
things and whatever whatever else i'm
i'm like where
where am i if i'm not right now um
but and also to be like very just
realistic of like the circumstances of
like what's happening
um and like so then what are what are
new ways of working them if i'm not if
i'm not looking back at
you know if you're like reading your
journal and you're like well look at
what i was thinking then you're like
that's so crazy or like i was so busy or
um you know like looking through
or um this thing happening now we're
like i'm getting at the point in my
planner we're like you know you'll pass
some things
like this trip or this show or this
whatever and i'm like
not uh and how to kind of like um
yeah like look at that and not blame the
self
or not i don't know just yeah how to
being more uh gracious
i was gonna say graceful but gracious
feels like the
best word for that or like also kind of
the
like reorienting time time towards dream
time
because i feel like this thing this
thing this thing about my
like um i mean relationship to sleep
uh and the times i'm allowed to sleep
right like being able um
like in the beginning i was just like
whoa i'm allowed to sleep
like i can sleep and so like what is the
this kind of reorientation that's
happening there
in terms of my dream space and what it
like what is it to i'm not a journaler
but i'm a hell of a dreamer
right and so i feel like that i feel
like i've been able to be in the journal
like like that's like i actually think
that that's like a relation
that i that i can recognize these two as
kind of being in a
like sisters uh in terms of spaces
um yeah and this feels like
uh like a like reorienting towards
allowing
space to go into deep sleep um
and so that that that has been a time
shift
uh for me and also i've moved out of the
basement of having a toddler live above
me for a really long time so like
clogged baby is no longer haunting my
dreams
and that is that's yeah this is like a
thing where it's just like what what
does it mean to
uh in a way like prioritize i know we'll
talk
like there's a lot of talk about
prioritizing rest but like what is it to
prioritize
the activity inside of dream space and
to
to to allow that that space to expand
and i don't know what that is doing uh
but it is definitely doing something
um yeah i don't know i feel like that's
also like another
this is a little bit of a a turn but it
seems
it seems maybe you know helpful here
like
so this space where we're meeting you
know now is
starting to concretize in a way or is it
i need to make it a question
is this space starting to be real for
you this this sort of
zoom digital presence and i wonder if
it's related to how much
time you spend in social media i have a
bunch of facebook accounts but i hardly
ever look
and you know i don't i'm not there much
at all um
so you know 15 years in i'm still not
really doing it
um but i wonder if you're feeling
that this digital self
and the ways that we have to then curate
or
figure out how to be our you know in all
of our queerness as it is
in these these sort of um platforms like
is it starting to become
[Music]
something that you recognize as being of
the you of you
jess how do you feel because i'm like
needed i'm like oh
i don't know i mean it's a very yes and
no question like i think i'm also
someone who
like i don't have a facebook account i
don't
like i and i'm like i don't post a lot
on instagram but when i do it's
golden no um but i keep it very private
like i don't like to use it for like
working like you know like
i just really like to like i'm like no
like when
you know shows like people are like oh
tagging my instagram or something i'm
like know that this is for my pleasure
and i'm not posting like dance wheels
i'm posting like
just me whatever um and but so i think
that there's
the one part and i was in a conversation
earlier today about this about this
digital realm and kind of like
do we like the resistance to shifting to
it
right in terms of performance like
teaching the classes online and
making the shows digital and making the
difference which is necessary in some
senses
right but also like as a choice i feel
it doesn't
still feel real and i think that if i
wasn't in the line
of they um it feels really weird but
like if my life wasn't aligned with like
such a physical
um uh
why is language so hard right now in
front of all these people
but if my work wasn't involved in such a
physical like
manner and like like really connecting
with people and reading energies and
like
you know looking at the body and like if
it wasn't if that wasn't so highly
valued then maybe now will feel real
but for me it will never be enough it
will never be real i will never select
my full self on this digital platform
um and that's just that's just the
breath talks about it
um and i don't and so then you were
mentioning earlier about even through
fear how then do you find ways to
connect and
i mean it's a lot of bravery because i'm
like i have to get over myself and i
have to get over my fear at some point
in very like you know not crazy terms
but because i do
need to that is something that i need
that's something that is like a part of
like
not only my survival strategy but like
my thriving strategy like
reaching for something beyond that um
yeah yeah i wonder i feel like it's just
like
i wanna i wanna i ask you jess like what
feels like the future of
what are you featuring right now
tonight like it's so we were talking
about this the other day like how hard
it is to like
look far forward yeah yeah yeah yeah
because of
so much uncertainty everywhere i'm like
i'm featuring like the things that i
know
myself my happiness like my love like
these cats that like i'm learning to
love but i don't like cats but i have
two kittens so like here i am like
does anyone want them no i'm gonna keep
them but like i mean i'm featuring like
myself
in these ways and you know hope to
myself like maybe i will
like be able to start my writing
practice again like as it pertains to
like my research
and i'm slowly but surely getting back
into it but i'm not able to future
[Music]
backtrack um
it feels um
i don't want to learn that that's what
i'm able to do now
um and that well it's not how it always
be because
things change and we change um
but i don't i'm like yeah i had this
question a lot in the beginning where i
was like finishing up teaching a class
a few classes online and i was like well
what if
it doesn't end and then we're still
having to do things on zoom
like what if we're you know year five or
like you know like whatever
but i just
i'm like will i just go five years
without like showing a thing which is
fine by me like i'd make work for myself
and nobody else
but like what what does that look like
and i don't and i don't know
which is fine with me to not know right
now
um i think that what i'm trying to be
more okay with is kind of
uh finding or
grasping and doing this like realizing
the losses
right like i was talking to the night
about how realizing now how much
my teaching practice is so central to my
other life practices
um and so how do then
like what is it specifically about my
teaching practice like how can i try and
cultivate that in other ways that aren't
just like me
teaching but like me doing that doing
those kind of sharing of things and
energy in other ways
and finding other ways to do it but like
i'm also not interested in just like
following in with the norm of everyone
doing everything i mean here i am i'm
like you have another zoom channel but
like
you know what i mean i don't feel the
need to like fall i don't need to like
jump in the water and like slow down the
stream like that's never been of
interest to me like
it's literally everyone was doing like
their show on zoom for the next four
years
i would still be that one that's like
it's not for me and that's okay
i i hear it yeah
like i'm late adopter and also like
secretly 70.
i just am like what i got on instagram
and the pandy because of femme
meditation because otherwise i was like
i don't know
insta what and it's not i mean it's like
i understand that it
exists but i kind of am like pretty slow
um but i feel like um
until i um
unders i don't know like until i have a
way to dream into being the thing that
needs to exist in this space
then i don't feel like putting it there
you know it's like i don't feel like i
can
do the thing i was doing here if i
figure
in some way what the thing that if if
there is something that needs to come
through me
into this space um
you know i guess in a performance way or
something like that then i can
i imagine making something for that but
i don't like
yeah i'm like holding back on writing
grants for this piece that is literally
going to be in a bath house and it's
going to be me like combing people's
hair
and having on you know what i mean this
is like honey that's
that's not corona friendly so it's also
like this thing of like what is it
that's getting put on pause
for a future that we thought we're going
to be doing um
in i think in terms of like what is the
um yeah like
if all of the work like you were saying
just like is centering around touch
and proximity and together
unless there's a together that i feel
uh called to here then i
then i think that my togethers will be
much smaller
um and like folks who are you know
folks who are in my pod folks who are in
my building folks who are in my
um yeah so it's just like
in a way it's like the world my world is
has
been uh
on that level um i think it's necessary
though
like like i was um today like and you're
like talking about grants like today i
was like
uh someone was what did she say she said
um
something about like these uh waiting to
see if like the bigger organizations
how they would come out of it and i'm
like yeah but like [ __ ] them
like like they didn't they haven't shown
up for us like we're all competing for
emergency grants to like buy [ __ ]
groceries
like we're like writing grants these
institutions who haven't done [ __ ] for
us this whole time
like we're i'm like how many people i
know who are like me making a hundred
dollars on unemployment a week trying to
what like and where where are these
organizations to do that like where is
like the grant for that
it feels so i think that's also why it's
hard for me my voice is so
loud and i'm talking so fast i'm slowing
down but i'm like it's so hard for me to
imagine
a future because so much of what was
happening was so
like not it's not it it's not it and
we're taught to think that it's it
because it's been the only way that
things have been happening
but it's so ridiculous and it's so
elitist and it's so capitalist and it's
so unnecessary
and i think that like people and i and i
mean like
we need to reimagine performance and
reimagine
like the way that we're thinking about
art and making and how it's
shared and how it's not shared and the
kind of like um
hierarchies it's been placed on because
of like the five people who have money
who can give it out
and we're all like writing these
applications trying to make our like
really weird [ __ ] sound like an mla
format essay in like english 101
people we don't know and who don't know
and it's like it's such a
it's uh for me it's such a crazy concept
and so to think about like a future
where i'm like show i'm like i don't
like do i want to show my work at any
me never get to show again because of
what i'm saying but i'm just like
like what like what do we mean when we
say when i have a show at like this
place or in that place
i'm like like why like why there like
why is that the thing that we want to
like aspire to
because we don't know anything else and
so like what else is there
and that's kind of like the beauty of
right now is that we get to imagine and
we get to like really
choose the future that we want we get to
like
what do you want to do how do you want
to show your work
you want to get your work in a graveyard
amazing you want to show your work
at the truck stop amazing like let's
make it happen like it's outdoors like
you want to work in a bath house
amazing you can only have an audience of
one at a time
perfect sign me up like what and the
show will have to be
three months long instead of like a
weekend like these are the kind of like
those are the kind of features that i
want to imagine but like
there's still too much power held in
these orchestra organizations who show
up too few and too little for all of the
individuals involved
[Laughter]
oh my god and there it is i mean
yeah i've been hearing you know
talk about hyper locality but also
intentionality and
intentional living and you know we've
been curious about these
not curious but we've been committed and
exploring
intentionality as a process and a
possibility
especially in terms of queer living and
um now we're you know we're compelled
um by the circumstance to to
to move towards that like to move to
actually be oriented towards just as you
were saying
jess uh something else like uh
one person at a time a grave like
whatever it needs to be
but letting it actually be what it needs
to be
rather than sort of fitting in to some
bankrupt systems that were set up
that were you know never about or
interested in us in the first place
um it's funny though i mean i i got
weirdly booked into a festival
and the show is next week and i have to
film it so you know
i'll be filming the show over the next
three days
and sending the file so that it can be
shown in the festival
um and it's in canada maybe maybe you'll
see it whatever
but it it it it's not that it feels
wrong
it just feels so incredibly different
that i don't know what it is
so i am curious about it because of that
well like the bureaucracy has become the
main event
to which we all bureaucratically look
bureaucratic
sorry talking after listening
bureaucracy and competitivity in all of
the systems are
the the event rather than
[Music]
the interaction of the humans that are
doing the work and
the folks who are in in in receptivity
with that
and so like what what if we're orienting
towards receptivity you know
anyway everything you said jess
everything oh my god
i'm just like thank you
yeah well we're in a in a in a place
where we should
share some um where are yous
now we should try that again like where
where are you we we were futuring just
now but
how about a a nowiness
now it is a now we-ness
after our night i keep thinking
about how erica asked me the other day
like what is jack what is your present
and i was like
what is my present because there's
something about the present that feels
so uneventful
right i'm like oh like my now is i'm
sitting
in this chair in my living room with my
feet inside of the stool that my
computer is on and i'm looking at my
snake plant which is thriving and
i'm hearing silence and finally because
the man in the hallway who was cutting
hair outside of my door is finished
feeling like really my you know my heart
is beating and there's movement in my
chest
and my mind is running and grateful for
that for that action because i've been
stagnant for so long
um and i'm grateful for people who are
keep
bringing me back um today and also
friends in the past who kind of won't
let me sit
and you know with stagnant which is
really amazing
um and i feel yeah i feel really uh
grateful
yeah i'm gonna follow your lead jess
um my present is uh
the tree outside my window is changing
color
because it's getting cold up here um
you can't see but the entire floor is
kind of covered in [ __ ]
because my partner and i are covered
moving in together and so
managing the the displacements of this
and
being both excited about that and a
little bit terrified
and also like blah blah blah and love
etc so feeling super grateful for those
and for that um
[Music]
yeah and then also like um
feeling again like holding who who is
here that's not here
like holding my my family with me and
not knowing when i'll
see them holding uh
holding i gotta change the word because
i don't wanna hold
i don't want to hold it i want to be
with it and i want to let it go
um feeling feeling the
uh the grief month which i mean my
partners
my partner who died in 2016 right before
the election they got out early
um uh their birthday is the 26th of
september and their death adversary is
the
is october 26th so it feels very much
like i'm right in the middle
of the the epicenter of grief season
and that feels different obviously
this year and so uh
yeah the present is
heavy with a window heavy with a window
that i can open
yeah and extremely grateful to like
because i think i was so nervous my
velvety nervousness was
bit was high before now
but somehow this this little taking
stock
and then being able to just be with
y'all has been really
yeah i've held my heart more than one
time in the last hour
in uh and that feels that feels
really great to be thinking together
with brilliant queers
thank you and tell me where you at
where am i at yeah oh thanks for asking
um
i'm distended it's the word i would use
i'm
i'm here and not here i'm appreciative
i'm with gratitude
to vibrate with you and to learn among
among the us of us like figuring out who
we are as a trio chatting but
but more than that with all the people
we keep bringing with us
and um this heaviness with the window
that could be open
i'm i work in a space where i can't open
any windows and that's the
construction model you know the air has
to be recirculated in a certain kind of
way
the windows will never be open where i'm
standing to talk with you
um so the heaviness the windows there
but it can't be open
so i'm um
i i'm looking i'm looking towards
more of this and it might be imaginary i
might imagine conversations with you
um jp and show up in your dreams ian i
have a habit of using initials i hope
that doesn't offend you
um great i love it okay cool and then
you know we will do this more
and i think that's the invitation of
blind's jaw is this kind of like
how do we keep assembling in unexpected
ways
and i think for now after this week i'm
going to need the
experiment to be imaginary because
there's my
imagining forward
or imagining through time
i want to invite everyone on the call to
unmute and
express gratitude towards the the
panelists we used that word before
but it's really towards the us of us and
our assembly
and our willingness to listen and learn
in
and receive and share and imagine
we want to thank the um herc and oh i'm
sorry i lost the name just a second ago
it's with a t thank you yeah trisha
are our asl um magicians and alchemists
for
helping to make the ideas keep being
able to be shared out
jared did you want to come in well i
just
i'm so um i mean it's so beautiful
to hear um
so much of so much shared experience and
so much
individual experience sort of fleshed
out in such a
beautiful way it was just so nice to be
able to sit back
and be in the presence of that so
i'm just feeling a lot of gratitude and
um
and gratitude to mit too and and again
to the interpreters who
just like it's amazing
um yeah i mean i don't have an official
way of closing other than saying thank
you and to invite people to tune in
tomorrow we have two more of these
um and uh
yeah thomas will be here again so will
jave marco hargiono and joseph pierce
um and um
yeah i i always i always desire like a
way of continuing these conversations
post you know the way you would hang out
in the hall and
do this after something but um
yeah that's really all for me just
extreme gratitude
erica jess thank you so much everybody
if you unmute and yell and scream
it's an amazing way to kind of bring it
to its next place
so i recommend it thank you
yes thank you thank you so much
thank you ciao